vraiment ces trois jours de deux
d'agonie à côté de la mer à lui tenir la
main où elle était complètement déformés
par la maladie avec le la domaine
extrêmement gonflé elle était tout jaune
parce qu'elle avait une jolie ce à cause
de sa maladie etc avoir vraiment a été
maigrissime commencé à avoir des
escarres d'être dans le lit et tout elle
avait une sonde
bref il ya fort c'est vraiment horrible
faire la personne qu'on connaît
totalement dégradée et au nom de je ne
sais pas quelle morale qui en tout cas
est pas la mienne on doit attendre que
son coeur s'arrête et tous restés au
chevet et donc à barcelon moment où ils
ont arrêté de la deûle alimenté par
perfusion ils nous ont dit parce que
nous on est terrifié de l'idée qu'elle
soit consciente de tout ça parce
qu'elles continuent à gémir à se tordre
de douleur dans entend pousser des cris
et ses forêts et les médecins nous ont
dit c'est fort probable qu'elle soit pas
du tout confiante donc
voilà il ya des réflexes corporels mais
donc nous on est très soulagés de sa est
en fait bon set est néanmoins difficile
voilà mais bon après dont on savait le
temps et puis voilà et en fait le
dernier jour avant son décès dans la
nuit
en fin d'après midi comme on n'a plus le
droit de lui on n'avait plus le droit de
l'alimenter in de lui donner à boire
vous pouvez pas lui donner à boire parce
qu'eric risqué de s'étouffer avec donc
cette énorme paradoxe de il faut trouver
quelqu'un s'étouffe mais on attend
qu'ils meurent enfin bref voilà et donc
on lui humidifier la bouche parce que
c'est horrible de bas à boire d'eau du
tout on est complètement séché et c'est
donc lui mettez de l'eau sur la bouche
c'était affreux
bref et enfin bref ça se voyait que
c'était très douloureux elle avait la
langue complètement sèche tout et donc
mécaniquement je vais demander est ce
que tu es ce que tu veux que je te
mettre de l'eau maman enfin vraiment
enfin parce qu'on continue à lui parler
autant pour elle que bongo est là elle
m'a répondu oui
alors qu'on pensait que ça faisait
toujours qu'elle ne s'entendait plus et
ça ça va ça va vraiment déchiré d'un
seul coup je me suis dit ah mais en fait
elle est officiellement consciente de
tout ce qui se passait nous entends plus
autour d'elle est tout même si on essaie
de le faire le plus discrètement
possible et je me suis dit mais quel
enfer ça doit être elle est coincée dans
un corps de douleur et c'est que la
seule issue possible si elle est
consciente dans la salle lucie possible
c'est mourir fois qu'elle aura quelle
horreur bref et plus tard aussi dans la
soirée il ya deux reprises des larmes
qui ont coulé sur ses joues donc
horrible juste affreux
bref et du coup les médecins nous ont
dit ça que ça on n'était pas sûr même si
elle a des mots ou des larmes que vous
ne pouvez pas être sûr qu'elles soient
conscientes et je l'espère de tout mon
coeur j'espère très fort que c'est
délicat mais en fait on ne pourra jamais
savoir et
et bref etc enfin je trouve ça terrible
tellement horrible de dire bien pourrait
rien faire et on est obligé de la
regarder la dent que ça soit fini on
était totalement impuissant envers sa
douleur à ses souffrances
moi je trouve ça fou qu'on connaît pas
le choix et surtout à partir du moment
où on dit maintenant on a débranché ont
fait plus rien il faut juste attendre
que ça s'arrête
mais pourquoi on pourquoi on fait
traîner français en fait c'est une
euthanasie très lente et douloureuse
quoi c'est exactement pareil on a coupé
les vivres donc totalement hypocrite
dans le cas où le patient a pu donner
dans la période où il était encore
pleinement en possession de ses moyens
ses capacités intellectuelles etc
son avis là dessus je trouve ça vraiment
dingue que l'euthanasie soit pas soit
pas une possibilité
bien sûr chacun choisit mais une
possibilité parce que ces trois jours
d'agonie moi aimons ça a duré trois
jours entre le moment où les médecins
ils ont dit on arrête d'alimenter votre
mère par perfusion et le moment où son
coeur s'est arrêté
enfin donné deux jours par mois
je vais préciser mais trois nuits et
deux joueurs bref et ça j'ai trouvé que
c'était extrêmement douloureux et
difficile permet tout ce qu'on avait
déjà enduré et que c'était vraiment pas
obligé voilà que peut-être on pourra
avoir le choix que ça se passe autrement
aujourd'hui en 2019 2020